entre deux et trois millions d'euros
c'est l'estimation folle d'une esquisse
de couverture d'un album de tintin le
lotus bleu
l'oeuvre est mis aux enchères jeudi à
paris tintin qui affole les compteurs
ça fait plus de trente ans que ça dure
la première vente aux enchères d'oeuvres
de temps en temps c'était en décembre
1990 à paris
au total des centaines de dessins et
d'esquissés d'hergé on les appelle
tintinophiles août un anneau maniaque
les amoureux du petit vais-je aux
culottes de golf était aujourd'hui crû
de 15 cents à se disputer aux enchères
500 lots dédiés à leur idole
parmi ces lots une oeuvre unique dessiné
par hergé enchère record pour une
couverture en couleurs des cigares du
pharaon plus de 3 millions de francs
c'est l'une des très rares couverture
dessinée en couleur par hergé lui-même
c'est donc le cigare le plus cher du
monde 3 millions 200 mille francs
en 1996 une nouvelle vente aux enchères
à la salle drouot à paris
près de 450 lots sont à vendre dont des
affiches les figurines des jouets
clou du spectacle un album unique de
1944 acquis pour 96 mille francs à
l'époque
dans la salle les tintinophiles sont
venus du monde entier parmi eux ce jeune
homme au physique tout droit sorti d'une
bande dessinée
depuis quelques années la plupart des
anglais sur leur tête jean ping et pour
voir ce qui se passe de ce côté lyncher
de passage à paris pour deux jours et
j'étais curieux de voir l'importance de
tintin et sociale devant
dans les années 2000 les prix s'envolent
c'est une boîte originale de tintin en
amérique qui est adjugé au prix de 7 164
1000 euros c'est un record mondial pour
l'époque
il faut désormais compter sur la bande
dessinée comme une valeur refuge au même
titre que l'or c'est vrai qu'il ya une
dizaine d'années lorsqu'on disait que
nous organisons les jambes de bd envoyé
pointe et çà et là quelques sourires
parfois un peu ironique 2012 nouvelle
vente aux enchères à paris et encore une
fois le record tombe 1,12 million
d'euros toujours pour ce dessin en
couleurs de tandt a en a mais berger n'a
fait que cinq couvertures dans sa vie en
couleurs directes à la gouache
celle ci s'est teinte en amérique de
après je dirais que c'est un vrai
tableau
là encore le record ne tient pas
longtemps en 2014
une page de garde dessiné par hergé à
l'antre de plume est acquise par un
acheteur américain anonyme
son prix accrochez-vous bien deux
millions cinq cent dix neuf mille euros
cette oeuvre a atteint après
extraordinaire parce qu'elle est
extraordinaire à l'est le résumé
finalement de toute une carrière de la
carrière d'hergé qui comme le
dessinateur le plus l'auteur le plus
connu dans le monde entier
[Musique]